escenas como estas se han convertido en
algo habitual en bagmut la ciudad se
encuentra en el oblast de doñesc y está
menos de 100 kilómetros de la doñaz
ocupada por Rusia de hecho según el
presidente bolo de mirtlenski bakmut
está sufriendo lo peor de los ataques
rusos situación
en el frente no ha sufrido cambios
significativos los combates más
encarnizados se libran en la zona de
donies bakmut AB did you can la locura
del mando ruso es ahora más visible allí
según los analistas militares tiene poco
valor militar en sí mismo Pero sigue
siendo un objetivo clave para Rusia y
está presionando agresivamente para
ganar el control de la ciudad
supuestamente desplegando tropas del
grupo Wagner un conjunto de mercenarios
fundado por el empresario vinculado al
kremlin Jeff Jenny prigogslin pero a
pesar del Fuerte empuje de Rusia los
avances son mínimos según kiev con las
tropas ucranianas en pie de guerra
las situaciones difícil pero sigue
siendo buena estable aquí estamos
estamos trabajando es difícil para la
ciudad y los locales pero estamos aquí
la ciudad tenía una población de 70.000
habitantes antes de la guerra un censo
que se ha visto mermado en gran medida
muchos residentes se escapan del
conflicto mientras pueden como esta
somos de la zona donde se está
combatiendo los voluntarios nos han
dicho que el otro ejército está a 500
metros de nuestra zona
están muy cerca ante ayer hubo un
bombardeo Y ayer pudimos salir como gran
parte de Ucrania la ciudad de bakmud
está casi reconocible desde hace seis
meses y los encarnizados con bates en la
zona no muestran signos de disminu